[Música]
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski acusó a rusia de cometer
torturas en misión una de las
localidades recuperadas por las tropas
de kiev en la región de jarque en la
ciudad continúan las labores de
identificación de los cadáveres
encontrados en fosas comunes tenemos
reporte desde el terreno
la espera para dar un último adiós a la
reina isabel segunda ya supera las 16
horas y la fila está a punto de alcanzar
su capacidad máxima lo que significa que
cientos de personas podrían quedarse sin
entrar a la capilla ardiente- antes del
lunes cuando tendrá lugar el funeral de
la monarca tenemos reporte desde londres
las personas migrantes enviadas el
miércoles a la isla de martha's vineyard
en massachusetts por decreto del
gobernador de florida fueron trasladadas
a una base militar donde santis defendió
su iniciativa mientras que la casa
blanca denunció el uso político de la
migración de cara a las elecciones de
medio término
buenos días bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24 en español soy rosa pérez
masdéu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en ucrania el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
acusó a rusia de cometer actos de
tortura en misión una de las localidades
recuperadas por las tropas de kiev en la
región de jarque a las puertas del
donbass las tropas rusas se retiraron de
la ciudad el pasado fin de semana y
dejaron al descubierto decenas de fosas
comunes
precisamente las exhumaciones empezaron
este viernes y la onu quiere investigar
posibles crímenes de guerra produjo
hasta el momento se han encontrado más
de 440 tumbas es demasiado pronto para
hablar sobre la cantidad de personas
enterradas allí las investigaciones
están en curso ya hay pruebas claras de
tortura de trato humillante a las
personas además hay evidencia de que los
soldados rusos cuyas posiciones no
estaban lejos de este lugar dispararon a
los ya enterrados sólo por diversión
debe reaccionar ante todo
adriana y el enviado especial de france
24 gulliver' drag nos mandó el siguiente
informe con la situación sobre el
terreno e inició
algunos residentes de edición que
todavía no tienen acceso a internet no
saben que este sitio existe estaba
escondido detrás de las posiciones del
ejército ruso en los bosques a las
afueras de la ciudad pero el viernes
bajo los focos de los medios de
comunicación internacionales los
trabajadores municipales y los
investigadores iniciaron el sombrío
trabajo la exhumación de las tumbas
hasta ahora hemos exhumado unos 25
cadáveres verá como hemos terminado esta
fosa ahora en volveremos el cuerpo y
luego pasaremos a la siguiente y así
procederemos con nuestras
investigaciones hasta que hayamos
recorrido todo el territorio algunos
fueron enterrados con sus documentos
estos bien pero potros y otros
equipos éstos eran soldados del ejército
ucraniano la causa de la muerte se
determinará sólo después de la autopsia
las explosiones son obra de las unidades
de desminado cercanas
los soldados parecen haber sido
enterrados en fosas comunes los civiles
individualmente los enterradores locales
dijeron que muchos murieron por las
bombas o los cohetes durante el asalto
ruso ahí se unen marzo y fueron
enterrados de nuevo aquí más tarde pero
no todos los motos como se encontró una
cuerda alrededor del cuello de este
hombre y signos de que esta cuerda fue
utilizada para asfixiarlo lo que
significa que puede haber sido
estrangulado
aunque no se puede ver en las imágenes
es la terrible sensación de muerte que
permea este bosque no se sabe
exactamente cuánta gente de aquí ni cómo
murieron lo que sí está claro es que
estaban vivos antes de que la invasión
rusa comenzará el 24 de febrero
y continuamos en europa con
consecuencias de la guerra en ucrania
berlín tomó el control de la filial de
la petrolera estatal rusa rosneft que
opera en territorio alemán el objetivo
del gobierno de alemania es garantizar
el suministro de crudo de cara al
invierno pero la compañía rusa calificó
la medida de ilegal y no descartó acudir
a la justicia
alemania prioriza su protección en
materia energética de cara a un invierno
que se anuncia difícil el gobierno del
canciller olaf scholz puso bajo tutela
de estado al grupo ruso rosneft lo que
significa que berlín se apodera de las
actividades de las filiales de la
compañía en alemania para asegurar el
suministro de gasolina diesel y
combustible de aviación rosneft
outlander representa el 12 por ciento de
la capacidad de refinación de petróleo
del país la tutela entró en vigor el
viernes 16 de septiembre y está prevista
para seis meses
esta es una decisión de política
energética de gran alcance para proteger
a nuestro país como descubrimos hace
mucho tiempo rusia ya no es un proveedor
de energía confiable con esta nueva
medida se asegura que alemania recibirá
petróleo a medio y largo plazo el
canciller se dijo estar preparado ante
una posible retaliación rusa con la
decisión las autoridades podrán asegurar
el funcionamiento y abastecimiento de
tres plantas de rousseff en alemania no
es la primera vez que berlín aplica
acciones similares en abril se tomó la
misma medida con gazprom germanía
también filial de la gigante rusa del
gas natural por su parte rosneft
respondió a la medida mediante un
comunicado arremetiendo contra la
decisión alemana y sin descartar la vía
legal
esta decisión es ilegal y de hecho es
una expropiación de la participación
accionaria como resultado de una
situación creada deliberadamente por las
sanciones pertinentes de la unión
europea y las acciones de los
reguladores alemanes y polacos cuyo
objetivo era embargar activos alemania
se ha comprometido ante la unión europea
a dejar de depender del petróleo ruso de
igual manera
a los préstamos a las empresas
energéticas que se vean afectadas por el
aumento de los precios del gas tras el
corte total del flujo del gasoducto nord
stream 1 por parte de moscú
y continuamos en europa pero vamos a
reino unido las autoridades británicas
alertaron de que el tiempo de espera
para despedirse de la reina isabel
segunda ya superar las 16 horas la
capilla ardiente cerrará el lunes por la
mañana poco antes del entierro de la
monarca por lo que la fila está a punto
de alcanzar su capacidad máxima
precisamente de cara al lunes londres se
prepara para celebrar el mayor funeral
de estado de la historia británica miles
de asistentes y cientos de dignatarios
se reunirán en un evento de máxima
seguridad en el que recordemos que ni
rusia ni belarús ni mianmar están
invitados previamente nuestra
corresponsal en londres louis ha pulido
nos detalló cuál es el ambiente en la
capital británica
buenas tardes es un ambiente de
solemnidad pero al mismo tiempo de
respeto son más y más las personas que
quieren seguir uniéndose a esta fila que
ya está en el sadat park que fue cerrada
porque alcanzó su máxima capacidad en
las horas de la noche del viernes por
fortuna ya ha sido reabierta esta fila y
el tiempo de espera ha bajado a 16 horas
pero el gobierno ha advertido que en
este fin de semana más personas querrán
unirse y seguramente podrá alcanzar esa
capacidad máxima entonces tendría la
fila que cerrarse y no podrán más
personas unirse ha habido momentos de
felicidad en medio del frío pese a que
está haciendo sol porque el rey carlos
tercero y su hijo william el heredero al
trono acaban de ir a uno de los puntos
de la fila en el lado sur del río
támesis en londres para saludarles para
agradecerles hemos visto mucha
emotividad por parte del público que han
agradecido el gesto pero sobre todo para
honrar la memoria de iu el 'segunda'
william por ejemplo les ha dicho a estas
personas que son muy valientes sobre
todo por hacer esas filas tan largas en
semejante frío entretanto en las últimas
horas fue capturado un hombre que
intentó lanzarse al ataúd de isabel
segunda durante la cámara ardiente en el
westminster hall la policía actuó
rápidamente pero no se conocen mayores
detalles
continuamos en europa en francia los
controladores aéreos convocaron tres
nuevas jornadas de paro los días 28 29 y
30 de septiembre el gremio exige una
mejora de las condiciones laborales con
aumentos salariales y más personal la
nueva convocatoria llega tras la jornada
de ayer viernes cuando se cancelaron
cerca de 1.000 vuelos y se registraron
múltiples retrasos de 40 minutos de
media
y este viernes se anunció un alto el
fuego entre kirguistán y tayikistán una
tregua frágil pero que se mantiene de
momento los dos bandos se acusan
mutuamente de bombardear sus territorios
kirguistán declaró 24 muertes entre sus
ciudadanos es una escena inhabitual en
kirguistán una manifestación pacífica en
el corazón de biskek la capital cientos
de personas piden cuentas al gobierno
por las recientes tensiones en la
frontera con tayikistán que dejan
decenas de muertos en el lado kirguís y
heridos en ambos lados los manifestantes
exigen el cese de las hostilidades y el
permiso para llevar ayuda humanitaria a
la frontera estamos a el objetivo de
esta acción no es la guerra no tenemos
armas no queremos luchar solo queremos
ir a ayudar a la gente los que tuvieron
que huir a través de los campos
necesitan comida no queremos
obstaculizar en absoluto el trabajo de
los militares los dos países comparten
cerca de mil kilómetros de fronteras que
aún no están claramente definidas este
enredo territorial es el origen de la
nuevas tensiones la región de batken es
una de las provincias disputadas por los
kirguises y tayikos cada parte acusa a
la otra de bombardear a su vecino por el
momento la presión parece haber
disminuido gracias a la firma de un alto
el fuego tras una reunión entre los
jefes de estado de ambos países en la
cumbre de la organización de cooperación
de shanghai en los bric están estas
tensiones son una herencia de la era
soviética en aquella época las fronteras
no tenían en cuenta las realidades
geográficas y étnicas dejando en algunos
lugares enclaves tayikos en territorio
kirguís el año pasado ya estuvo marcado
por los enfrentamientos entre ambos
países con un saldo de al menos 50
muertos
el líder supremo de irán el ayatolá alí
jamenéi reapareció este sábado tras más
de dos semanas alejado de los actos
públicos
su ausencia desató rumores sobre el
posible deterioro de su salud por un
lado el 'new york times'
citó este viernes a cuatro personas
cercanas a jamenéi que aseguraron que la
semana pasada estuvo bajo observación
médica por una grave enfermedad sin
embargo dos fuentes próximas al líder
negaron a la agencia reuters que la
salud de jamenéi se haya deteriorado la
reaparición del ayatolá de 83 años fue
retransmitida por la televisión estatal
de irán en el marco de la ceremonia
musulmana del arbaín
y vamos a eeuu este viernes el
gobernador de florida ron de santis
defendió el envío de personas en
situación administrativa irregular a la
isla turística de martha's vineyard en
el estado de massachusetts un acto
deplorado por la casa blanca
una inmigración irregular es nuevamente
campo de batalla en temporada electoral
tras haber sido enviado sin previo aviso
al balneario turístico de martha's
vineyard en el estado de massachusetts
estos indocumentados en su mayoría
venezolanos fueron trasladados por orden
del gobernador a la base militar de
kapkot preparada para situaciones de
emergencia defensores de los derechos de
los migrantes se les ofrecieron ayuda y
criticaron este proceder de las
autoridades republicanas del sur del
país puede ser irónico que esté mejor
aquí en massachusetts que en texas pero
la realidad es que nunca deberían
haberles puesto en esta posición porque
no se sabe que les pudo haber pasado
el traslado dio pie al gobernador de la
florida ron de santis para defender su
decisión de enviarlos al norte y para
arremeter contra la supuesta doble moral
de los estados tradicionalmente azules
con políticas más tolerantes con los
inmigrantes
esta es una política masiva intencionada
que está causando un enorme daño en todo
el país y todo tiene su origen en la
incapacidad de bailén de ocuparse de que
las leyes se ejecuten fielmente y de
cumplir su juramento así que en lugar de
preocuparse un puñado de gente rica y
porque tenga 50 inmigrantes y por cierto
ya los han echado ya se han ido dicen
que quieren a todos que nadie es
ilegales y los sacaron en 48 horas
para la casa blanca al accionar de los
republicanos es claro usan a los
indocumentados como peones políticos de
cara a las elecciones de medio término
de worms eran niños eran madres que
huían del comunismo y que les hicieron
el gobernador de santis y el gobernador
a abdú to be the news de menos tratan
como bienes materiales en un truco
político cruel y premeditado primer
trader número constante ya son al menos
10.000 inmigrantes los que han sido
enviados desde texas y arizona
trasladados a territorios controlados
por demócratas como nueva york y
washington
y cerramos con imágenes del regreso del
oktoberfest en alemania tras dos años de
suspensión por la pandemia cientos de
personas locales y extranjeros se
congregaron en múnich para celebrar esta
tradición alrededor de la cerveza y de
la gastronomía bávara muchos de los
asistentes aprovechan la ocasión para
vestirse con los atuendos tradicionales
de la región de baviera
muchísimas gracias por su atención
sigan con nosotros en france 24 y france
24 puntocom
[Música]